i just got to talk to you and dwayne
over zoom about the book
but now we are here in person how did it
feel mama to get dressed up and look
amazing it felt so good to just
get out of the house you know she there
were a couple tears from from cove at
the door
she was like have fun mom i'm like i'll
be back and she's like
i'm like go go go
that's gotta be hard for every parent i
think getting out of the house is like
half the battle
right but tell me how you picked this
dress because you looked amazing and
kavia did she approve because she has
opinions she thought i looked very
pretty she was like
white dress and i was like good
and she was like you look pretty mommy
cobb's approval but no i wanted
something a little classic a little sexy
with a you know a little bit of razzle
dazzle and
prada came through
can you say valentino buy it is it true
that coffee just got her first valentino
valentino was kind enough to send us
mommy and daughter matching bags
so for everyone who thought i bought my
child a
3 000 plus dollar bag when she can't
poop in the potty on her own
no no but thank you to valentino
for sending those and she was like she's
been literally sleeping with it
you